East London a conference centre
commandeered to provide 4,000 new beds
in giant hangars today 87 more deaths
the biggest spike so far and a quarter
of them in just one North London
hospital the government still ramping up
its response I can announce today that
we will next week
open a new hospital a temporary hospital
the NHS Nightingale hospital at the
Excel Centre in London the NHS
Nightingale hospital will comprise two
wards each of two thousand people with
the help of the military and with NHS
clinicians we will make sure that we
have the capacity that we need so that
everyone can get the support they need
why the need in London it's the most
densely populated part of the country
and still people are packed together on
tube trains going to work not all of
that work essential to fight coronavirus
people who want to stay at home can't
and risk the sack if they do defy their
employers instructions we have been
incredibly clear about the rules and one
of the reasons that we strengthened the
rules yesterday and essentially flipped
the basis of the rules so it's not do
whatever you like so long as you don't
do the following it is stay at home
unless you've got a good reason and we
will also enforce against those rules if
people don't feel safe in their work
environment they should always raise
those concerns and I think by far the
majority of employers are being really
sensible and supportive and there's been
huge support for for staff if they don't
feel that safety then I think it's
reasonable to highlight that very firmly
with their employer this emergency seeps
into every corner of people's lives can
partners who don't live together see
each other if you're too
individuals to hearth of the couple are
currently in separate households ideally
they should stay in those households the
alternative might be that for quite a
significant period going forward they
should just test the strengths of their
relationship and decide whether one
wishes to be permanently resident in
another household a government working
like never before for a challenge unique
in the modern age and this is only just
the start
Sam Cote Sky News